[musique]
c
voir
Et tu es mon cœur
[musique]
sur vous
Où es-tu, oh oiseau, oh oiseau, oh ciel, où es-tu ?
Ministre, Ministre, peu importe qui est avec toi, on se demande où tu es, oiseau
Ô oiseau, ton chéri, le paradis est avec toi, Yaz, Yaz qui est avec toi
tu es insulté
Et dis
Sur toi si
[musique]
Kansh
k Pour toi, oh oiseau, oh oiseau, et ma vie est à toi, nous allons changer
Et nous changeons
Et nous avons peur, Yair
[musique]
Oh cher
Wong de
pour de
[musique]
à
Où es-tu, oh bien, oh oiseau, oh musc du Paradis, où es-tu, Yaz ?
Celui qui est avec toi, nous te félicitons, oh oiseau, oh oiseau
La touche du Paradis, où es-tu, oh toi qui es avec toi ?
[musique]
Et un coeur
sur vous
pour de
[musique]
à
g
Tu es là